[Music]
did you guys see that photo of a human
being a hand sanitizer stand what see
this photo it was circulating does he
work or outraged because they were like
this is dehumanizing oh come on
humanizing so this a Saudi Arabian oil
company they hired this dude or omits
the hole Kobe crisis and he was just
standing outside the company serving as
a human sanitizer hand sanitizer humans
getting punished or is that he chose to
yes he's like an intern is getting paid
I don't know the answers to those
questions
I heard hired yeah they did hire him I
don't think he want or like he's doing
this for kind of job on Craigslist I
didn't find any information in terms of
like whether or not it was against his
own will in the photos he does look
really sad smiley he could be like this
my thing though it could be like this
but some people don't mind is he is he
does he come to you or you still got to
walk the fool dis I think I need to keep
my head up I can't do that at Trader
Joe's they would handing out the baskets
they disinfect the baskets and they
before you walk to the store they spray
they gave me a hand sanitizer - oh so
like a lot of stores are implementing
this as well so I don't think like is
dehumanizing I think is this but is it a
person dressed as a hand sentence I know
but I think that I think that just
raised a little more to it like also you
can like see you can see who's not hand
sanitizer yes
people feel more pressure to do it yeah
dude all those folks come here I see so
many [ __ ] at the airport who don't wash
their hands oh my god those
[ __ ] better be watching their
hands now I did I said what they're
probably not they're not no one in the
airports now except for Joe I would say
be able to dinner this past Friday and I
use the restroom I walked out me walk to
this thing and I watched my cat's y56
like four four and back you know 340
seconds let's wait twenty let's be able
to sing the Happy Birthday I'm actually
don't even sing I don't know how long it
is and there's no proper way to wash
ringing happy birthday song Casey wait
that's what you did never seen this I
never wash my hands so thoroughly until
all these videos came out and I'm like
oh sure you guys sing happy birthday
twice alright twice twice twice oh happy
happy birthday from all of us to you we
wish it was my birthday so we could
party to be happy but anyway this guy
they walked out behind me like he just
put his hands on in the water just like
and then walk out I was like you haven't
heard my birthday song he's like this is
your birthday song it isn't very long
they use no salt dough Steve oh just
what his hand under the water it was
just like this like I and that's like a
child that never learned how to wash
your hands because I remember when Isaac
was like three like really really young
yeah I would I would ask him like oh did
you wash your hand he goes yep and then
I watched him and then all he does is
just wet it and then walk away and I'm
and then so since then since I saw him
do that I would always smell his hands
first a bit maybe you didn't wash your
hands with soap you need so I don't have
to like wash his hands with my hands and
that's how I've taught him how to wash
hands but I think a lot of parents just
were like oh yeah just wet oh man that's
cool and I think just people are lazy
cuz like you gets a like the guy that
did that it's late thirties early
forties you old enough to know I think
you blame the parents yeah
Oh parent thing I feel like as a parent
you just get tired of being a broken
record you just want something to show
them in that's your job as a parent I
know that's why you guys when I get
pregnant doing this cavite well don't
think it's like we've been skipping our
cycles too cuz I'm like mmhmm yeah yeah
wait to see how long it's gonna go that
yeah I can't even take it outside to get
like sunlight for it take the kid on the
walked again front of a TV like this
there's new channels that are right oh
because I did see some articles saying
that people are now virtually visiting
other cities because they're just
quarantined so they're like VR was
before yeah finally yeah Google Maps is
our moment you go anywhere it does you
will [ __ ] around because the Google
came up with this thing called Google
cardboard and then I never saw you put
your phone in there and yeah I'm one
jump in the water it's not Google Maps
can you jump in your bathtub Oh in the
apple the Apple aerial screensaver yeah
you know those like for the Apple TV
yeah they have some new ones where
you're like following dolphins
underwater it's really cool well it's
pretty cool the thing that's nice about
Google Google cardboard is like you said
we got it for free when we got to go to
the convention or whatever any like cool
I got something for free and then like
it's just a little box you put your
phone inside of yeah but it works
I played scary VR stuff in it it was
pretty cool I play games
you put your headphones on I want a
[ __ ] headset bro was afraid it was
thousand dollars what they were trying
to show was that like you could have it
with a cardboard box you didn't have to
get like the cool thing and it was the
same experience it did this is so cool
about the oculus and [ __ ] is that it
knows where you are in the room cuz you
put the sensors up and [ __ ] so another
Facebook thing you know they all in
oculus it's a CC vibe is better I think
yeah I got faithless not oh yeah
I got a flex office I gotta have a share
me my friend win all right
you don't tell me nothing feeling bad
cos you're close shows got canceled now
I'm like I don't feel about anyone that
didn't go down everything goes $12,000
in a matter of days we didn't lose it
cuz you didn't sell anything that's
right keep hold onto all your back and
shares did you sell everything let's go
$20 so some people need to sell just to
have cash though I would much rather
sell my body to settle stock sometimes
we go back up yeah I thought this boy
puts in in the sale before I get away
with a guy hands like a Photoshop of a
giant we had this chat and it was just a
whole bunch of penis photos being sent
in with the same black guy and then
there was one that was photoshopped with
these vagina it's it's it's crazy
because so like our business partners in
our food group youth you would think
they are the most cleanest innocent
Silicon Valley type people humor in the
world I'm like this [ __ ] has brought the
crazy out of you guys cuz horniest yeah
the most perverted yeah my
brother-in-law is a [ __ ] chemist and
he's got his own lab it like UCLA or
what are you saying
[ __ ] and he's a [ __ ] degenerate
with humor degenerate yes yep this
practice chat group needs prayer room
holy water
you can only send so many naked black
guys looking at that come hither before
getting creative though they merged that
famous black guy with the bat together
because they're sending fake links that
leads really creative with it
my group chats are popping off too much
on my phone I just threw my phone on the
toilet because I'll just like sick of my
phone everything's muted but then I go
to it and it's like 600 missed messages
I'm like I don't even open it and then
close yeah I read all like the edit read
all and then you can do that yeah if you
pick your phone up there's like 800
missed messages if you just put it to
your ear it automatically start doing
the audio memo oh really
yeah so like if you if you I don't know
if you have to do it with the this is
great for everyone like put it up to you
right here hey just testing out this
audio memo thing that you're talking
about you don't like it no cuz this
listening to me it's always now is just
started listening to you they've been
listening
we know that Alexa listen to me yeah we
had a Google home and then his brother
gave us and his girlfriend gave us a
Apple home pod or housewarming gift is
it cooler it's pretty sick it's way more
responsive yeah it's really good and
it's really pretty too
yeah I kind of judge what kind of free
music comes with this so no I connects
to your Apple so we have the Apple music
subscription like the family thing so I
pay for this yeah no I want free music
Alexa has the best Spotify so you have a
lot of ads no there's no ads what no no
ads yeah Alexa has the best [ __ ]
playlist we're gonna have three virtual
assistants and it has the best cleaning
playlist and like Alexa play some
relaxing music she plays the best
relaxing music
so I'm having a cocktail party put some
cocktail music she plays the best
[ __ ] so what's your streaming um I
think I think Alexis and Spotify maybe
yeah for the music terrible hey Google
Play some oldies it starts playing like
rap music I'm like name hey Google Play
Google ha was connected to my wife
Spotify so it just plays whatever her
playing this off of the day of our
specific playlist like that look you
think 90s music you think like like
Britney and you think like a mix of like
R&B and like Amy's pop oh nice 5 and
90's and like 90s alternative rock songs
but like popular you think of popular in
MTV yeah okay so Alexa plays that but
Google home thinks just but rock it's
just [ __ ] but rock like oh yeah that
one scott stapp I know we have to skip
songs a lot more on our google home than
yeah yeah Google home sucks
I like Spotify I think a little bit more
than Apple music I'll be honest with you
like I make playlists for both and I
find it I typically start on Spotify
what I'm making my playlists yeah like I
just like it a little bit the interface
is better on fire I've never made a
playlist in my home I think we talked
about this right you only got like two
songs on your phone right yeah don't
listen to [ __ ] on my right it's so
annoying
[Laughter]
I do listen investment [ __ ] no tell me
why you're having the coldest oh [ __ ]
yes no no no I listen to any music that
is so good I don't want to
somebody disagree that waterfalls
beaches music I have a playlist for
everything I everything I used to have a
playlist definitely not like while the
TV's running because then I get distract
him just watching what's on TV so we
have to play the TV loud sometimes the
drowning out because of the kid play it
down a lot American Dad
real loud and she is the music's you
know was going on like she kept me home
with the music in the music alone you
can get Jeremiah you like y'all a day
for the ball
[Music]